85 of the total mineral in your body
is a calcium there's 147 different
diseases you can get from a calcium
deficiency we're just going to quickly
go over the top 10 when it comes to
number of people affected and the amount
of money involved let's look at
osteoporosis the number 10 killer of
adults the united states
remember 75 percent of the those over
age 65 who fracture a hip or major leg
bone don't live 90 days also it's the
most horrible disease when it comes to
human misery and dollars expended
osteoporosis think of the special vans
and the lift gates and the ramps and the
elevators the special plumbing and homes
and public buildings special parking
places wheelchairs and walkers and canes
think of the beds and the chairs are
little electric motors to lift you up
when you can't stand up by yourself
physical therapists joint replacement
surgeries pharmaceuticals doctors visits
we're talking billions and billions of
dollars for nothing more than a calcium
deficiency disease now as horrible as a
disease as osteoporosis is in human
beings we don't have osteoporosis in
animals because we don't have blue cross
blue shield major medical
hospitalization medicare and medicaid to
pay for nonsensical surgical treatments
for mineral deficiency we've learned
that by putting animals who are weaned
off their mother's milk on calcium as
soon as they're weaned they won't get
arthritis and osteoporosis it's amazing
how that works receding gums denison
dental hygienist will tell you to floss
and brush after every meal
if you believe that works i have some
oceanfront property in montana to sell
you if you have receding gums
periodontitis gingivitis pyrea loose
teeth bridges and plates you actually
have osteoporosis of the facial bones
and the jaw bones we don't get receding
gums and animals even though they don't
floss or brush that's because we've
taken care of the osteoporosis problem
in animals arthritis 85 of all arthritis
is called wear and tear arthritis
osteoarthritis degenerative arthritis
ankylosing spondylitis these things are
nothing more than osteoporosis of the
joint ends of the bones
hypertension high blood pressure as
you've learned has nothing to do with
salt or salt restriction 85 percent of
hypertension not related to kidney
disease which is most of them not
related to kidney disease is in fact a
calcium deficiency insomnia is not a
deficiency of sleeping pills halcyon or
barbitus it's a deficiency of calcium
kidney stones bone spurs heel spurs and
calcium deposits again the medical
profession has a malignant dumb belief
that these things are due to too much
calcium in your diet try to give up
calcium
when in fact you only get kidney stones
bone spurs heel spurs and calcium
deposits when you have raging
osteoporosis you actually need more
calcium more magnesium not less cramps
and twitches raise your hand how many
have you ever had a toe cramp foot cramp
leg cramp in your life sure that's the
first symptom of a calcium deficiency
that most people recognize so if you've
ever had that sometime in your life
you've had a calcium deficiency then you
have pms the university of california
san diego came out and said that 85
percent of the emotional and physical
stuff of pms can be relieved eliminated
and cured they use the cure word by
taking three times the rda of calcium
low back pain has nothing to do with
disc problems i know you've heard of
people maybe even yourself have had a
disc surgery for back pain and after the
surgery you still have the pain maybe
even worse because back pain is not
caused by disc problems if you have a
disc problem you can have numbness and
tingling maybe even paralysis if it's
very severe but disc problems do not
cause pain